it is a difficult time but for prince
harry and i'm not just talking about the
paparazzi situation
[Music]
beyond the level of harassment that he's
having to deal with which i know
is upsetting harry the idea that he and
meghan can't go out without being
followed
the fear that paparazzi will literally
cut through their security fence
to get access to the gardens to
photograph archie at play
if that wasn't enough of a pressure for
harry he has the
added pressure of now having to forge a
new life for himself
in a country he doesn't know without an
infrastructure
and without the level of support that he
enjoyed when he was
a prince of england he's moved to a new
country in the middle of a pandemic
they've had to live through lockdown
harry doesn't have the infrastructure
there that megan has of course she's got
her mother
she's got close friends harry has none
of that he doesn't have a
clear plan or a clear agenda there is a
degree of trepidation
and apprehension about the future and
don't forget
the couple are also under a lot of
pressure there are two
potentially big court cases involving
the two of them
megan's court case against the mail on
sunday who published
excerpts of her letter to her father and
prince harry taking on the tabloids over
historic
phone hacking allegations add to that
this new legal action
against the paparazzi pictures and i
think they are
very much in a pressure cooker situation
there see
look archie it's flying flying
it's hopping it has been reported that
megan had
told friends that she was concerned that
archie wasn't getting enough
socializing time with other little ones
his age
and i think in that respect megan
probably shares the same concerns of
many mothers with young children
who are living through the lockdown and
my understanding is that megan and harry
have been quite strict
and they've obeyed the lockdown to the t
and they haven't been socializing they
haven't seen
friends and really the only person that
they've spent an intensive period of
time with
is megan's mother doria which is of
course wonderful for them as a family no
doria really hasn't seen much of archie
growing up and i think
they're really making the most of that
family time but the impact
on them as a family of not being able to
socialize for harry not being able to
make friends
and for archie as well not being able to
have those playdates which
you know harry and megan are very keen
to him to have they want
archie to have a normal childhood they
want him to enjoy play dates
they want him to socialize with children
of his own age and at the moment
that's simply not happening they are
still house hunting and i'm told they
are looking for somewhere
away from beverly hills away from the
hollywood fray
where they can escape the spotlight and
i think when you look at prince harry
and the childhood he had he lived his
childhood out very much
under the media spotlight you can
understand why he doesn't want archie
to be subjected to that same scrutiny
one of the key issues for them
is that they are in the spotlight that
they do attract a huge amount of
attention
and their concern has always been how
they would balance
their private lives with their public
roles
now i think a lot of people might think
that they have been naive in expecting
a greater level of privacy in la america
has different privacy rules
to the uk and i think it's worth
pointing out that while they were living
here
in britain there were no paparazzi
pictures of them
there was still a gentleman's agreement
between the press and the palace that
when the principals
the senior members of the royal family
were enjoying private time
that was private time that was respected
so
if the couple were packed then the
british newspapers
agreed with the palace that they
wouldn't use those paparazzi pictures
and as a result of that agreement which
worked
you didn't see paparazzi pictures of the
sussexes while they were living in
england
within a matter of days of their
location being
identified by a tabloid newspaper over
here in britain
of where they were actually living the
couple were essentially
under siege and it was only a matter of
time before they were photographed
there is no doubt in my mind that if
they were still living at frogmore house
in windsor there would not be this level
of intrusion it simply would not be
tolerated
i was told when they moved to la that it
would be open season on the sussexes and
that if they had gone to
la hoping for a quieter life where they
could duck out the spotlight they were
sorely mistaken